during the 60s Salvy is barely on the
radar of the Mafia and the main Irish
gangs in Somerville and Charlestown in
the North End the Mafia dominates the
city's organized crime from here
Godfather Gerry and jewel oh and his
consul iary Larry Zunino take a cut from
the rackets run by other gangs crime in
Southie however is small-time but even
here gangster still have to pay a street
tax to the Mafia competing street gangs
run nickel and dime gaming and
protection rackets James Bulger is an
enforcer and debt collector for one of
them but Bulger's gang has rivals seen
here in a rare and battered old
photograph a cocky young group of
robbers led by pat nice we would thief
we'd like to steal and we like to party
and we might make enough money at once
to go at the last two or three months
but while we're all partying would
always be looking for the next for the
next one these gang operates in the
South Boston docks in what is now the
Connelly terminal one of their
specialties is raiding parked trucks
full of the daily catch
a lot of money into nutrition crabmeat a
lot of money in items that is sold every
day goods that are consumed every day
that's what you would like to steal one
night in July 1969 in the same month
that Niall Armstrong makes his giant
leap for mankind
knees men are celebrating another
successful heist a drunken brawl breaks
out with some of Bulger's gang members
by chance
both knee and Bulger are in another bar
nearby when they hear what's happening
the two share a ride to the fight
knowing they are about to become mortal
enemies and we pulled up mean whitey
just kind of looked at each other eyes
as well be the last time we'll be
talking on this level
see you later he says see you later dena
the shield started the war lasts from
1969 to 72 at first its knees gang who
are on the receiving end
dodging Bulger's bullets in a deadly
game of cat and mouse knee tries to hit
back without success he and Bulger are
soon stalking each other we've actually
run around the projects in the middle of
the afternoon I had a rifle with a scope
he had an automatic weapon of some sort
and I kept trying to line him up in the
scope and he kept moving fast and I
couldn't get a clean shot so I didn't
take it this in the middlee afternoon
and no one's seen anything that's what
Boston was like back then
but the war turns ugly when knees
brother falls victim to a Bulger
associate when Peter got killed I
decided I could kill and I started
hunting me is an ex-marine with combat
experience in Vietnam he tracks his
target with cold-blooded
single-mindedness one cold and wet night
in November 1969 knee finally confronts
his brother's killer I finally trapped
him coming home
I creeped up the alleyway as he's
packing and then when he turned around I
said what's your turn and I opened up on
them because I shot him over the hot
under the hot blew out his right lung I
think I hit him twice in the stomach I
thought I hit him in the hot and when he
went down I kicked his teeth out my spin
on it incredibly these brothers killer
survives but now Bulger knows that rival
gang leader Patni is a dangerous
opponent as war is breaking out among
Irish gangs in South Boston to the north
another Irish gang war is ending